yeah he has been growing very healthily
and I think the tremendous opportunity
that we look forward for it to continue
that kind of pace of growth and really
involved every citizen in the country
and the key to making that happen with
Bellini technology adoption like the
innovative technology adoption the Lord
of unfilial spirit throughout the
villages or the districts and in the
urban areas how do we really encourage
that innovation spirit to drive
technology adoption whether it be
education whether it be health for their
governance
I think this plenty of opportunities and
actually if they are conceived the way
showing lot of the youth and we keep
talking about India's demographics and
the youth are really participating in
driving this innovative technology
adoption to enable the inclusive growth
that the country really needs project on
we going